And Joy Boy has returned, Luffy seemingly died and
then came back to life, and a new power awakened
inside of him – a power that could be a completely
new form, a devil fruit awakening, or something
even more insane! The One Piece story has reached
the point at which a massive reveal like this
had to happen in order to set up a proper final
showdown on Laugh Tail, but by making this reveal,
Oda may have just spoiled Luffy’s true power
and how this incredible story will finally end,
so let’s get into it!
Like, sub.
Playlist.
Spoilers.
So in the most recent chapters of the manga, the
CP0 members on Wano learn that the Gorosei have
issued a critically important edict – Straw Hat
Luffy must be eliminated at once! He must not
be allowed to defeat Kaido; he must be stopped
right here and now. As soon as we heard this,
we all immediately wondered why the
Gorosei are so determined to kill Luffy
at this very moment. They are not even willing
to wait for Luffy’s fight with Kaido to end;
despite the fact that Kaido is known
as the world’s strongest creature,
a man who seemingly cannot die, the Gorosei seem
to think that Luffy has a chance of defeating him,
because the nameless Cp0 agent with the white
bowler hat seemingly sacrifices his life in
order to interfere in the Luffy and Kaido fight.
As a direct result of the agent’s interference,
Luffy takes a massive blow from Kaido head on.
He is sent crashing to the ground, he loses
consciousness, and he is defeated. The narrator
confirms that Kaido is the winner of the battle,
Momo also says that he can no longer hear
Luffy’s voice, and Kaido then declares
that Monkey D. Luffy is DEAD. At this point, it
doesn’t look great for Luffy, and if he wasn’t
the main freaking protagonist, we might have been
tricked into thinking that he had actually died.
But Luffy is the main protagonist, and as the
chapter comes to an end, we see Luffy’s supposedly
lifeless body begin to smile. Steam is rising from
his body and his hair has turned into some sort of
goop, as if it is melting. It is also implied
that Luffy’s heart had in fact stopped beating,
but then it started up again. The Japanese
word used to describe Luffy’s smile as he comes
back to life is NIKA, as in The Sun God Nika.
And as all of this is happening, Zunesha arrives.
Zunesha, who is now confirmed to have
been a companion of Joy Boy 800 years ago,
says the following: MOMONOSUKE, I CAN
HEAR IT! HOW LONG IT’S BEEN. I HEAR
THE DRUMS OF LIBERATION. FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
800 YEARS… HE IS HERE! JOY BOY HAS RETURNED!
What an incredible chapter, what an insane
cliffhanger, and as you might expect,
this unbelievable turn of events has made the
One Piece community lose its mind. And for once
it’s completely justified. The long-awaited Joy
Boy has returned, he is clearly implied to be
the same person as the legendary Sun God Nika, and
Luffy who was supposed to be dead has now returned
to life with some sort of new form or new power
or devil fruit awakening or all of the above!
Okay so let’s talk about Joy Boy and
Nika, what we know about them so far,
and how both of these legendary and mythical
figures seem to have awakened within one man,
Monkey D. Luffy. On the Ryugyu Poneglpyh, a
man from the surface known only as Joy Boy
apologizes to the people of Fishman Island for
breaking his part of an ancient promise. This
apology was written during the Void Century,
and the nature of the letter shows that this
Joy Boy had a strong connection to the people of
Fishman Island, despite the fact that he himself
was from the surface. This is significant in and
of itself, because although our knowledge of the
Void Century is limited, due to everything else
we know about the history of the One Piece world,
it is safe to assume that back then the Fish-Men
were actively discriminated against by people
on the surface. And yet Joy Boy clearly wasn’t
one of those who discriminated against them.
Joy Boy is believed to have lived some 900 years
ago, so at the beginning of the Void Century,
but since the Poneglyphs are believed to have been
invented by the Kozuki clan some 800 years ago,
the Ryugyu Poneglyph must have been created
around the end of the Void Century. So there
seems to be a gap of about 100 years between
the time that Joy Boy is believed to have made
a promise to the people of Fishman Island, and
the time that the Ryugyu Poneglyph was created.
In terms of the promise itself, the people of
Fishman island promised to keep Noah safe until
a certain day. Keeping Noah safe was their
part of the promise. Joy Boy’s part of the
promise was most likely that he would
use the power of Poseidon to bring Noah
up to the surface. It is also likely that Noah’s
true purpose was to serve as an arc that would
relocate all the people of Fishman Island up
to the surface, something that many Fishmen
have dreamed of for centuries, but we were never
able to achieve due to the rampant discrimination
that they faced on the surface. Again, Joy
Boy is someone from the surface who not only
refuses to discriminate against the Fish-Men, but
actually wants to liberate them and bring them up
to the surface. This tells us a lot about Joy
Boy, and it draws a clear parallel between him
and the legend of the Sun God Nika.
Joy Boy is also the man who left a
priceless treasure known as the One Piece on a
mysterious island at the end of the New World.
This island was discovered by Gol
D. Roger and his crew 25 years ago.
Since the people of Fishman Island continue
to faithfully watch over Noah in order to
keep their end of the promise to Joy Boy,
it is implied that this Joy Boy will one
day return to fulfill his part of the promise
to the people of Fishman island. And now we
know that he has indeed returned, even if we
don’t know all the precise details just yet.
Now let’s talk about Nika, a legendary warrior
that was worshipped as the Sun God by slaves
in ancient times. The legend of Nika says
that he would one day come to liberate
all the slaves and bring smiles to their faces
– and again, bringing freedom and joy to those
who are oppressed is something that both Joy Boy
and Nika have in common. Combine this with Zunesha
talking about the drums of liberation, and there
is a strong implication that Nika and Joy Boy are
the same person, an ancient warrior who wanted to
liberate those who were enslaved and oppressed,
including the Fishmen. Luffy appears to be
the modern embodiment of this ancient warrior,
and so he may be destined to succeed
where the original Joy Boy failed.
The most recent chapters foreshadowed this very
thing, because during the battle between Kaido
and Luffy, we saw Luffy going all out and trying
to surpass his limits because he is so concerned
about the people of Wano. He knows that if he
loses to Kaido, the people of Wano will continue
to be enslaved, and they will not even have clean
water to drink as their homeland continues to
be polluted by Kaido’s factories. This is the
primary driving force behind Luffy’s desire to
defeat Kaido – he wants to liberate the people
of Wano from their enslavement, a goal that is
certainly consistent with the idea that Luffy
is the modern embodiment of Joy Boy and Nika.
Meanwhile, Kaido, who was himself once
a potential candidate for being Joy Boy,
has the exact opposite goal. He wishes to continue
enslaving the people of Wano for his own ends,
and the fact that they dared rebel against him
means that he is now justified in treating them
more severely than ever before. Perhaps Kaido
had embodied the spirit of Joy Boy at some point
in his past, but that is clearly no longer the
case. On the other hand, Luffy fully embodies
the true spirit of Joy Boy and Nika, and that is
almost certainly why he is now undergoing this
incredible transformation right before our eyes.
But speaking of this new goopy transformation,
what exactly is happening here? Is Luffy
simply awakening a new gear or new form,
is he awakening a new ability, is his devil fruit
itself awakening, or is the actual spirit of Joy
Boy/Nika awakening inside of him? Is this
new resurrected Luffy going to be the same
Monkey D. Luffy that we love, or is he going to
be different now because a new consciousness has
awoken inside of him? Is Luffy going to become
the historical person known as Joy Boy, is he
going to stay the same but unlock new powers, or
is it going to be some combination of the two?
These are the big questions that we need to
talk about right now. The best place to start
is Luffy’s devil fruit, because the manga has
been hinting heavily that the Gomu Gomu no Mi is
far more important than we had initially realized.
It seems clear that Luffy’s fruit is not actually
called Gomu Gomu no Mi. Its true name was hidden
by the World Government, because this devil fruit
is a secret legendary fruit that hasn’t awakened
for centuries. This devil fruit is so dangerous
that the World Government tried to keep it
completely under wraps, but Shanks managed
to steal it from the World government, and then
Luffy accidentally ate it when he was a kid.
But assuming that Luffy’s fruit is the legendary
fruit that hasn’t awakened in centuries,
why is it so dangerous? Was this
the original Joy Boy’s fruit,
and does it still have some part of him inside
of it – perhaps his will or some special power
that he possesses? Is this even a rubber fruit
at all, or could it be something else entirely,
and the rubber may just be one
small aspect of its true powers?
Now this could be just a standard devil fruit
awakening, similar to Katakuri’s mochi mochi
no mi, which has many similar properties to the
gomu gomu no mi. Luffy may develop the ability
transform his body like a logia user, and he may
even learn to turn nearby inorganic materials
into rubber. This would certainly be a sick
powerup for him, but if this is all that’s
going on, then the whole Joy Boy is back stuff
doesn’t seem to be related to it. Luffy’s devil
fruit could awaken like Katakuri’s without Luffy
dying and being reborn as Joy Boy, so the heavily
emphasized Joy Boy connection seems to indicate
that there might be something else going on here.
Because it’s been implied that the gomu gomu no
mi is not the real name of Luffy’s devil fruit,
it is possible that rubber related powers are
just one aspect of the fruit’s full potential.
Maybe Luffy can use other abilities
beyond just rubber-based powers,
and he just didn’t realize it yet. For example,
maybe his actual ability is burning rubber, so
a combination of fire and rubber, or a combination
of rubber and lava, or rubber and another element.
There is also a lot of speculation that Luffy’s
real devil fruit may actually be a Mythical Zone,
like the Monkey King Sun Wukong fruit. I
think that this would be extremely cool;
I’ve read A Journey to the West and Sun
Wukong has some a lot of awesome powers,
and of course Luffy’s character definitely
has that Monkey King energy. But even though
the Monkey King fruit would definitely be a good
fit for Luffy, the fact that his devil fruit is a
dangerous legendary fruit that hasn’t awakened for
centuries means that it is likely directly related
to Joy Boy and Nika. And I think that in order
to better understand how Luffy’s new power could
directly connect to two legendary ancient figures
like Joy Boy and Nika, we need to go back to the
beginning. And by that I don’t just mean the
void century, but even before the void century.
We need to go back to over 1,100 years ago in the
world of One Piece to the advanced civilization
that inhabited the moon, the same civilizations
whose descendants are modern day Skypieans,
Shandorians, and Birkans. But to find the
answers we need, we first have to go to go back
3500 years in our own world and take a look
at the Olmec Civilization of Mesoamerica.
Now it is pretty clear that the Ancient
civilization on the moon, along with all
of their descendant civilizations, are heavily
inspired by ancient Mesoamerican civilizations,
including the Aztecs and Mayans. The parallels are
blatantly clear when we look at the architecture,
art, and culture of these civilizations
in One Piece and compare them to the real
life Mesoamerican Civilizations. I mean this
particular statue of Quetzalcoatl the Feathered
Serpent god from Aztec religion seems to have
been directly taken from real life and drawn
into One Piece (Shandora in episode 174 vs.
Real Aztec Statues of Quetzalcoatl’s head).
But while I’ve seen a lot of talk about
the Sky civilizations being inspired by
the Aztecs and Mayans, I rarely hear talk
about the Olmecs, who predate the Aztecs and
Mayans and without whom the Aztecs, Mayans, and
other Mesoamerican civilizations would not have
existed. The Olmec are considered to be the
first major civilization of ancient Mexico,
and their history dates all the way back to 1500
BC. This is many centuries before the Aztec and
Mayan empires would flourish in Mesoamerica.
It is believed that the Olmec civilization
pioneered many of the things that later
Mesoamerican civilizations would become known for,
including that famous Mayan calendar, the ball
games that the Mesoamerican people played,
and even the gods that they worshipped. It can
all be traced back to the Olmecs. So the Olmecs
could be seen as the ancestors of the Mayans and
Aztecs just like the Moon People are the ancestors
of the Shandorians, Skypeians, and Birkas.
But here’s the crazy thing about the Olmec
People. Olmec literally means THE RUBBER PEOPLE,
because they lived in an area that was known
for producing rubber. Now Olmec is not what the
people called themselves, we don’t know what they
called themselves, but this name was given to them
because of the rubber-producing area that they
inhabited. The Olmecs did not leave behind any
written history or oral traditions, so everything
we know about them comes from artifacts, and from
the influence that their civilization had on the
civilizations that came later. If this gives you
the same vibes as the moon civilization and the
void century, trust me, you’re not the only one.
The Olmecs are probably best known for creating
giant head statues, some of which are over
3 meters in height. These stone heads are
big enough for a certain Giant Straw Hat at
Mariegeoise to fit them. And speaking of giants,
the jaguar is a very important sacred animal in
Mesoamerica, so it is possible that the giant
Jaguar D. Saul will turn out to be
more important than we even realize.
Now many people have heard of the Aztec god
Quetzalcoatl, who often takes the shape of
a feathered serpent. Some have discussed
the potential connection between Luffy
and Quetzalcoatl in the past, especially
because Quetzalcoatl was the god of the sun
and of the dawn, as well as of the winds and the
sky. Nika is the sun god, Joy Boy and Luffy are
going to bring about a new dawn, so Quetzalcoatl
the feathered serpent may be an even better fit
for Luffy’s hypothetical mythical zoan devil
fruit than the monkey king Sun Wukong. But
most people don’t realize that this divine
feathered serpent that the Aztecs worshipped
as Quetzalcoatl actually originated with
the Olmecs, who also worshipped a feathered
serpent deity. If the sky races represent the
newer civilizations such as the Aztecs and Mayans,
then the moon civilization represents to Olmecs,
and so the truth about Nika, Joy Boy, and the
true nature of Luffy’s legendary devil fruit
may lead all the way back to the moon itself.
And the similarities between Nika, Joy Boy,
and the feathered serpent deity that came
to be known as Quetzalcoatl don’t end there. The
rulers of ancient Mesoamerica would often equate
themselves with Quetzalcoatl, implying that they
were his current incarnation or reincarnation on
earth. The Aztec people believed that Quetzalcoatl
would one day return to earth, and according to
some historical sources, when Hernan Cortes and
the Conquistadors landed in America in 1519,
Aztec Emperor Montezuma II believed that
Cortes was actually Quetzalcoatl returning
to claim his throne. Whether this is actually
true is still disputed by other historians,
but this idea of Quetzalcoatl being incarnated
as different rulers and returning to earth to
claim his throne definitely gives off strong Joy
Boy and Nika energy. Side note, but Gan Fall and
his armor seem to be a direct reference to Spanish
Conquistadors, which again stresses the parallels
between Mesoamerica and the Sky Peoples.
Even in terms of his personality,
what we know about Quetzalcoatl echoes what we
know about Joy Boy and Nika. Although in modern
western culture serpents are often associated with
sinister things, Quetzalcoatl was actually a kind
and gentle deity, and he did not want to harm any
living creature. He was a benefactor of mankind
and he gifted them incredibly valuable
knowledge, including farming, medicine,
and other important crafts. He was loved by the
people and he brought them joy. Oh and if you’re
looking for a monkey connection, in his form as
Ehecatl he is the wind, and he is represented
by spider monkeys, among other creatures.
So if the key to Luffy’s new transformation
and the ending of One Piece itself lies with the
Olmecs and their Mesoamerican descendants, do we
have any clues about what Luffy’s new power could
be? Well shapeshifting is a very popular power
among Mesoamerican gods including Quetzalcoatl,
and since he can take the form of a giant
feathered serpent, he can also fly and his powers
are associated with the sun, the sky, and wind.
In terms of the rubber connection, the ancient
Mesoamericans were the first peoples to invent
rubber balls, and they were a very
important part of their culture.
They could be used for playing ball games, or
as important religious offerings, among other
uses. Another Aztec god who represents the morning
star Venus, and whose name can be translated as
Dawn Lord or Lord of the Dawn, is associated with
powerful rays that are able to hurt people and
crops. The interesting thing about this deity
is that there is a known image of him burning a
rubber ball, so again that whole burning rubber
and melting rubber aspect could come into play.
Also you might have noticed that I didn’t tell
you this deity’s name, so I guess I have to do
that now. Sigh. His name is Tlahuizcalpantecuhtli.
It is important to mention that to both the Aztecs
and the Maya, the rubber latex that flowed
from the tree represented blood and seamen.
Rubber was symbolic of fertility, of new
life, and was often burned, buried, or laid
in a sacrificial pool as an offering to deities.
Now I don’t think Luffy’s power will be that
other thing, but something associated with
blood could be a part of the equation.
Bloodletting played a massively important part in
Mesoamerican religions, and Luffy has already used
a form of blood manipulation as far back as Gear
Two. He has also used air manipulation to blow air
into his body, so that wind and air connection
to Quetzalcoatl could also come into play.
All in all, I think that there are many
fascinating theories regarding Luffy’s new form
and powers, and his connection to Joy Boy. I’m a
fan of many of them, including Sun Wukong theory,
but I don’t think we can underestimate the
importance of the Rubber People – the Olmecs – and
the Mesoamerican connections to the ancient
kingdom, the void century, and the civilization
on the moon. Joy Boy, Nika, the gomu gomu no mi,
and the one piece itself are all going to take us
back to the ancient kingdom, and the best clues
we have about the true nature of that kingdom
are the real life kingdoms that inspired it.
Let me know what you guys think about Luffy’s
new transformation. What is his connection to Joy
Boy and Nika – is he inheriting this divine will,
is he a reincarnation of this legendary warrior,
or is something else going on? And of course,
what new powers do you think Luffy is about to
unlock? Awakened gomu gomu no mi, a completely
new element like fire or lava, or does he actually
possess a mythical zoan fruit like the sun wukong
fruit or the feathered serpent fruit? Don’t forget
to leave your feedback down in the comments below.
if you guys enjoyed this one piece
video and you want to see more in
the future leave a quick like and comment
it only takes a second but it helps a lot
and remember that subscribing and hitting
that notification bell is a very real
and completely free way of supporting the channel
you can also hit me up on twitter and instagram
at animeopror as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya space cowboys